so we are pleased to offer today on
Christine Apache wells
about linked open data for those of you
who want to tweet you are going to just
do the hashtag linked jazz so for those
of you want to have a conversation on
Twitter about this that'll be great
contributed so i'll just do a brief
introduction before I do that I want to
thank Rob eaglets who has helped with
planning into this series which is a
part of our digital seminar program and
our digital humanities center sponsored
talks so Christina pacha wellies is an
associate professor at the school of
information in library science at the
Pratt Institute her research focuses on
information organization and knowledge
representing representation methods and
tools applied to information systems and
digital libraries in particular and
she'll be talking thank you thank you
for the introduction and thank you for
inviting me thanks all for coming I'm
delighted to see so many people
interested in this kind of I don't know
obscure abstruse topic in emerging an
emerging topic in our area anyway what
I'm thinking to do today is to start
with a an overview of linked open data
it might be redundant for some of you it
might be hopefully not too technical for
others and then give some examples of
the application of linked open data to
cultural heritage and handing the top
today with sharing my own experience in
crafting forging link open data for a
project called Lynn jet and through this
talk I think all the poor to some of the
opportunities and challenges of building
this new ecosystem of information will
emerge I also would be grateful if you
can stop me any time and make this more
than a talk just a conversation but I
will start with they're not general
definition of lean data which is a math
word a series of banks practice is
actually for publishing structured data
that makes it possible to interconnect
interlink data from different
heterogeneous sources and integrate this
data into a unifying global discovery
environment so linked data is actually
the implementation of the vision of the
Semantic Web for those of you who have
familiarity with the Semantic Web all
have accumulated some frustration like
me what with the Semantic Web for the
number of years modeling very complex
and logically formalized oncologists but
working on a project would never
materialized link data actually
represented the actual implementation so
we moved from the face of advocating for
for a semantic web to to adopting to
building it one important implication of
implementing the same atom linked open
data environment is the ship the ship
the torn from an idea of an environments
focus on the document a document centric
perspective towards an entity centers
perspective and this is very important
for people who deal with cultural
heritage because cultural heritage is
made up of things like entities like
people places events organizations
anything any topic and so linked open
data allows to focus to apply
representations to individual units of
information beyond
the document into to make it possible to
use that information that is currently
hidden in documents and make it
available opening openly available on
the web and we talked about web of data
as a new discovery environment so when
we think of a place where we look for
information in the context of linked
open data we think too we think of the
web as our database and so what there is
some this alignment you to the past is
from from mac to pc but i hope you don't
mind so linked data aims to connect more
fine-grained bits of data and the
connection occurs through relationships
links but these links are are given a
meaning so we are easily they're called
tight relationship but version there
have been represented in in an explicit
way so linked data is all about
generating relationships and if you
think of connecting data the granular
level in new ways you can always we can
start imagining and visioning an
environment where we are giving new
opportunities to read the data to read
information to pay new path to access
the way our new ways to navigate
information and ultimately a new
approach to interpretation the success
of link data is due in part to the
faculty relies on an open framework and
a set of open standard there
to be easy to use so basically these are
the main principles are as Tim
berners-lee has laid them out and you
have to remember that we are talking
today about linked open data so then
openly accessible opening license
version of link data which is a
community effort and is also endorsed
and promoted by the w3c so the three
main components of link data are
assigning your eyes so unique
identifiers to things giving things a
name that is globally recognized huge
HTTP to make these names being visible
you can look up the URI thanks to the
HTTP and so you can look up what what
the names refer to either humans or or
software agents and then these pieces of
information they are named they are also
organized within a model a data model
called RDF resource description
framework it's a common format is the
model that creates unifying context in
which data can interact interlink it's
important to spend a little time on what
are the afia's because it's a critical
technology beyond linked data RDF is a
language is a grammar with a grammar
which is relatively simple is made up of
statements that are composed by a
subject predicate and an object so all
we can say will be structured in this
way let's say that we want to describe
the longest month so what we do is
we have a subject this entity here is
given a URI the URI can be taken from a
number of sources and we'll see later we
say has named the predicate an object
tell on his mom now if we translating
linked data not only the subject has a
URI but also the relationship this link
is explicitly declare is make it
readable by the machine and it's very
important to to think of where this your
eye is taken from and if you want to say
this entity has named telling us mom we
will look for vocabularies hard year for
capillaries establish popular
vocabularies in the contest of linked
data that provided the source of
predicates for us and so his name would
be taken in this case from a vocabulary
called forth might come across this this
weirdly called knowledge tool it means
friend forth means friend of a friend so
we can take name from it if we wanted to
say Thelonious Monk is the creator of
April in Paris is the Creator will be
taken from another vogue cover I would
take it from a dublin core vocabulary
where there is a element creator in
dublin core as many other vocabularies
including a lot of covers from from the
libraries have been converted in rdf
format so they are eligible as source of
of semantics for linked data and so the
result of of our our construction is a
triple like this
these are the building blocks of linked
data you see here a a subject the
relationship and the object felonious
mom turns mark here is what is called a
literal so you don't see any links here
is it literal triple but if we put it in
the context of the data structure that
statement looks something like this but
we can add any other RDF triples and
start creating and gluing together
semantics and linking things to each
other in a way that is meaningful for
the machine by adding a URI here instead
of it simply a literal name we will we
will make it possible to link this
portion with other other statement does
it make sense does it convey the idea
that hold the power of linked data
stands in this your eyes and so what we
have now the current information we here
now on the web is connected through
hyperlinks but these are hyperlinks
don't express the type of connection
with two between to pay yeah these
hyperlinks don't tell us which kind of
connection is held between two documents
or two pieces of data they just say
there is a connection what link data
does telling is telling you the
relationship is for example has name is
created is a friend of so using the LOD
approach a resource can be linked to any
other resource by simply
adding a triple one of those three poles
we have seen earlier that just express
relationship between the resources with
the traditional search environment the
linkages would be just left to the users
to make so you would have to we all
would have to interpret these linkages
make inferences between data from
different sources with this technology
we are able to access information in a
unified way visually it would be
something like this it is actually
something like this you see a network of
link so you can navigate these links
there are different ways to access link
data and again now we can only imagine
them we have it we have a few examples
but is still in the making by the way we
we access link data could be by
navigating them through their connection
and the approach is called follow your
nose all this link data can be crowned
by robots and then aggregated integrated
a number of things can be done on that
so this is how hardly of triples are
woven into the fabric of the web of data
and then they can be navigated as a
static roll by the robot well this is
the most popular way of visualizing
linked data how many of you have seen
tis cloud it's everywhere every time I I
swear that I won't show it again but
but is is still it's still powerful and
what we see here is a number of nodes
each node represent a data set of link
data each node holds massive amount of
bling data from various sectors now
government data have really grown
incredibly and so and so they occupy a
big chunk of this cloud but libraries
have been contributed lean date in the
last few years 2010 and think that this
cloud grow grew 1,000% then to the
library's contribution and this is an
old picture is still started September
2011 because the cloud is growing and
bevan figure out a way to visualize so
much linked data but what happens here
is or what this picture conveys is a
year that all these data sets are highly
interlinked to each other and what is
really interesting is when triples are
kinetic to other trifles from once in
manteca one domain to another is where
the synapse it's interesting synapses
can occur I was thinking of what are the
benefits of the data and I the poor for
aspect that I think needs to be stressed
the idea of sharing data the idea of
reusing data the discovery of
information and the integration of
information and I think at this point
sharing and reuse is something that has
become best practice and the Linden
communities doing it heavily is one of
the
ways you create link by reusing what is
there you remember when I mentioned the
four vocab you take the Mounties from
what from from where it is already so
she reviews is something that we are
doing pretty well the integration in the
discovery are where the research
challenges clay and his work also
research has moved is focus now so
people have worked in the last few years
you have to think that linked open data
start in mid-2007 so it's relatively
recent have created who these huge
repositories and put them available for
the community to use and now is the time
to build interfaces or to build tool to
con tools to consume this data one of
the most important repository data set
of linked data heavily huge use in our
in the in the Linda community is dbpedia
is the biggest one because it's derived
by extracting information structure
information from Wikipedia so the
magnitude of dbpedia reflects the
magnitude of a Wikipedia and it's a
semantic hub where everybody is taking
linked data because there is everything
is a generic general repository and you
find anything there the also there is
the implication of dealing with a
repository dealing with with data they
are contributed by people by volunteer
so that the quality is not always the
most accurate but they're certainly the
wealth of information is incredible and
in this case all right I put up a a
human friend
friendly view of DBP this is a page for
Columbia University's much longer but
you see all the possible linkages from
here and how typically linked data looks
like is mostly code like this for
developers but in this case you have the
possibility to browse information and to
see her number of linkages and the type
of representation that DP belial dbpedia
offers well in the certainly with this
idea of putting their data available for
other the newer times has been a pioneer
they converted their historical index
into linked data a few years ago and you
will see a number of these data sets
where the data are available for people
to build their own applications most of
the time the data sets are for being
used by someone else when you're times
did a wonderful job in also offering api
api sways on access this data broken
down by articles by geographic
information event so it's a very curated
set of data the Library of Congress has
also put their authority files available
as linked data and the libraries have
really contributed a massive amount of
high quality linked data which is not
what the PDF provides and
oh the data that you get from the
Library of Congress are typically the
ones that you use for increasing the
quality that curacy the consistency of
your of your own data and so you are for
example noted the authority names with
all their the URI the naming and all the
variants and related terms so I think I
person never been sparkler among
developers because it's really an their
tools are at points of reference for for
everybody developing linked data but
most of the time you see the data that
looks something like this the British
Museum converted their entire database
of objects into linked data and again is
open for people from grasp for people to
use it and the only interface they
provide is this one's pretty scary and
it shows actually the query query system
that link data use it which is called
Sparkle if you hear Sparkle this is that
the language to query this data is the
derivational s cube well but is is made
in a way that it can query triples so
now we need a little imagination we
cannot envision the benefits Aldean data
could bring to the discovery of
information the interpretation the use
of digital heritage there is a massive
amount of semantics out there to be
consumed to be exploited what people are
doing now is developing in the form of
prototypes
creating working prototypes creating use
cases to discuss proof of concepts so I
just have a bunch of I've selected a
number of examples that these are they
give us a sense of what is possible but
again it's just the beginning and so
let's start with Kennedy Anna which is
thinking consortium in Canada of
cultural heritage member institutions
that they want to integrate share and
integrate their objects and so they
study with creating a proof of concept
called out of the trenches so they
focused on First World War and here
there is their idea of integration the
quality is not excellent because this is
a screenshot from the video they put
online and that working on this but this
is a way to demonstrate the value of
using linked data so in this case by
aggregating integrating pulling together
metadata and data from a number of
sources they were able to for example
create history or the story of this
soldier so the sources are are for
example the repository of work poster
the repository of war songs from the
authorities they got all these input
biographical information little birth
there the place and a number of other
documents could be well photographs of
the soldier before he left with the
other members he was part of the black
crow with other members letters that
first letter is sent to he sent home
clippings from newspapers because these
are taken from a collection of
newspapers and it just gives you a sense
of what can be done things can be
aggregated putting together and creating
new stories now these are all the
participants organization in this case
the aggregation the integration is done
by mapping the metadata from different
institutions through this model mapping
against ontology had the avant ologies
it's not the first time we see an
integration of documents like this what
link data brings to the table is the
fact that you don't need for creating an
integration system to hardwire your
semantics into the system but the
approach does not require that you
define for example the linkages Apriori
in advance and so you can even even fall
for the metadata that the protocols are
used they don't need to be agreed upon
in advance so is a completely different
method of wars you use what is available
you could you can cooperate obviously
but without the need to coordinate to
come up with a pre-emptive agreement you
use what is already available because it
is in a format that is kind of a lingua
franca
doesn't make sense does it start to make
sense other examples this is the risk
Museum of Amsterdam in collaboration
with other memory institutions in the
Netherlands they liquid this is a
working prototype on the service
probably fulfill a flight service where
they decided to offer the possibility to
aggregate documents pictures or objects
according to the spatial dimension with
a with the idea of offering the end user
the possibility to create new story and
have a new approach or a different
approach to the interpretation of these
objects but this is only one possibility
space geospatial data are available and
heavily used but there are a wide range
of possibility to aggregate object
another example is this open images
which is a project open media platform
where people can access videos and
photographs and this is another
repository of objects and linked data
that is heavily used in the hinterland
king with evidence the interlinking with
the I think again the Amsterdam use you
the only condition is to make this staff
available in this format and then you
can take your triples and you can
interleave them
we saw earlier the answer in museum is
probably the institution that has done
most they have converted everything into
into link data and and there are their
data sets are heavily heavily consumed
and used for for example semantic mobile
two reps and many other many other
services this is only a way of
showcasing possibilities but again
almost all the initiatives are still in
the beta stage and they are prototypes
and everybody is is working on on on
creating new services so you're a sense
of this potential that is there and
relatively easy pneus of doing linked
data or is the reset a learning curve
but it is truly something that you you
can accomplish with a little Python
programming knowledge and and some some
knowledge of this kind of modeling
environment now at this point I would
like to share what I've been learning in
the creation of linked data for a
project I worked on for over two years
now is called injured and it was
initially funded by OCLC and it was for
me actually way at the beginning to
experiment with this new technology of
improvising him in the jazz environment
applying the this technology to digital
archives to jazz history
I'm showing this because it seems to me
it could be useful to give the sense of
the challenges that we have in digital
archives we know that digital archives
might have very poor meta data if Annie
but jett history archives are terrible
to this regard because they have not
much stuff digitized and available and
what is available is mostly to showcase
their collection but it's not that you
can rely on on good metadata it's only
the libraries that have this tradition
of first of all collaborating and
sharing metadata and creating high
quality metadata also because they deal
with standardized they've been always
dealing with standardized documents so
they have been so active in converting
metadata and providing to the community
with this this accurate representation
but this is not the case with museums
that deal with unique objects and they
have another way another approach to
access to information and certainly not
archives traditional archives they have
descriptive tools that describe the not
of the item level let alone at the data
level so the collection lab and they can
be of little use in the in the linked
data environment so we went all the way
from the beginning and just following
all the other steps of creating forging
crafting this this data with it with the
purpose of being able to link networks
of people to net worth of information in
other words with the idea of uncovering
representing
the dense network of relationship
personal professional social
relationship that have held in the Jazz
community something that is very well
documented in discographies in the
literature is very difficult for the
user to capture at least on a large
scale so what we wanted to do is to
create a tool that helped to identify
make explicit make a split this network
of relationships from aurelie stories we
work with text interview transcripts
this was our goal then we started from
scratch well also now the goal in a
broader way was to offer to create a to
that was useful to researchers and also
for public engagement for reading and
analyzing the history of jazz in a new
way and and also ultimately contribute
to the link link data community by
exposing archival data to the web for
other people to exploit and to make
possible to create across domains
cross-domain interlinking so who yet
deal was text some digital I some just
given to us as manuscripts and and so
the the challenge was how do we identify
the names of the people here which is
the first step for extracting name from
the arguments so we have this text and
how to how to find out what names are
here because our assumption was if
someone here in interview site someone
else it's very likely that this person
has some level of knowledge of the other
person it could be just knowing the name
or been a close friend or being a
collaborator we don't know but there is
some kind of linkage there so the first
step was create a name directory of jazz
musicians then huge use this directory
to match names from the transcripts and
convert this matches into RDF triples
one of those triples we saw earlier well
what we found ourself doing was a lot of
data preparation data analysis data
curation and I'm assuming from what I I
see people doing this is what you should
expect to do at this point when you work
with linked data there is kind of a
convergence in building tools for
cleaning up data for mapping data and
there are the first end of the first
generation of these tools probably in a
short time these tools will be available
for others to use but when you work with
lean data you need a way to create a
sound and sound set of data to work with
so first of all create the name
vocabulary my first choice would have
been the Library of Congress authority
names but but it was not already it was
not not converted in the interlink date
I think yet but in any case there is no
way
to detect the role of it in a thority
name because you don't know which one is
a musician only occasionally you have
their all stated so it was not possible
to use this vocabulary and I'm here to
do a number of other steps like mapping
and and build a number of tools mapping
accurate or visualize or crowdsourcing
and transcript analyzer I will show them
briefly just to give you a sense of what
is needed and what is also interesting
to to build so we needed a vocabulary
that was made of these statements for
being able to assign your eyes to all
these people there's a first step the
natural choice was defeated in DBP that
there is everything very few musicians
obscured musician are left out maybe
from Wikipedia so you have to extract
data from from the BP dia and you all
for the best well we were able to create
a directory of over 9000 musician so
it's pretty decent directorial of names
but it's it it was any still incomplete
because you have pretty good we would
say prefer name unifor name or preferred
because they are extracted from this
portion of the info box you recognize
the info box on each of our Wikipedia
pages is where dbpedia extracts its data
so it depends on the quality of the data
that provided by by by the volunteers
typically the names is good quality and
is always there because it's a mandatory
field but when it comes to
two nicknames stage names holder variant
forms of names it's it's it's not
reliable who wants to put the actual
birth name on most of the time people
don't know this information so what what
is here is kind of not high quality high
quality data so the first then the next
step was to create have a way to
normalize our date and then reach them
with the variance and so we built a
personal name mapping tool and here we
see a the interface too heavily
automatic process where we on this side
we have our directory and then we are
the possibility to map against Library
of Congress we have and also Wikipedia
name this process is done automatically
and these are the results so you have
different levels of confidence in this
case you have a perfect match Mary Lou
Williams date of birth date of death
correspond to the library of congress is
done but then you have different levels
but you also have the possibility to
manually verify your data and i think
one piece of of informational lesson
that we received from from this
experiment is that a mix and hybrid
approach machine driven and human ribbon
is the key for creating trustworthy data
set so you can you can verified manually
Yavin in cases like this now ha Thomas I
Cohen we are to Alicia the machine
cannot really say which candle Alicia
he is our preferred by our our our
vocabulary and so by looking up the
Library of Congress you see that one is
was born in the seven in 1971 78 and
boom you have your quality perfect match
done so these kind of tools are being
built for the purpose of link jet but
they are basically domain agnostic so
they're mapping tool that can serve and
number of porpoises and so it's kind of
fun I would say the first generation of
tools but I seem nypl many other many
other institutions or initiatives they
are building things like this because
they are needed and and then you you get
your own kind of authority oregano say
but anyway your your name and reach with
all the possible variants it's obvious
like that if you have all the variants
you can perform a better mapping against
your transcript because people can be
named can be cited in many ways and then
this probably is the two that gave us
more satisfaction because now it shows
up your your musicians in their social
network and again the visualizer is
interesting tool browser-based so you
don't have to plug in anything download
anything and it's it shows many views
dynamic and fix views of the social
network based on the data set now sure
no not yet Lee to say yeah that's
actually at this point we could only say
that relation between these people is of
nose of taking this predicate from
another established RDF vocab recalled
relationship I don't think we can say
anything more but they let someone knows
of someone else yes because if it's this
person side someone else is very likely
that at least they know the name of the
other person but that at this point what
we want to do in the spirit of lingane
is to get meaning to these relationships
now they are implicit they give you most
of the time social networks they stop
here so you can do some pattern analysis
but frequency closeness but what we want
explicit semantics we want to know which
relationship relationships are held
between these people so at this point
the machine is done you have to employ a
human driven approach and and we are
doing by creating a crowdsourcing tool
that asked people to interpret the
nature of the relationships based on the
transcripts so what and that's why we
build I'm saying we build but to be fair
all these tools are built by one of our
students Matt Miller was a phenomenal
developer and so thanks to him we have
the possibility to showcase all these
tools and to see link data happening
otherwise it would still the kind of
only only
I to to the vision or imagination but
the link just 50 second street is the
crowdsourcing tool that allows to map
the relationships between jazz musicians
based on human analysis this tool is
under like user testing these days and
what it does it gives the interfaces
already change but anyway gives a
selection of of interviews and people
can pick what they want and they are
presented snippets have the transcript
answer questions structure and by an end
on down there on this pain you have all
the people they are mentioned in this
portion of the transcript and we ask the
user the volunteer the contributor to
pick one of the relationships from these
option menus and we also give you an
incentive so they can see that they are
contributing contributing to to creating
the network so this is our way to
harness the knowledge of jazz
enthusiasts just researchers but to get
to this point you need to work on the
preparation of the transit transit don't
come broken down into q and A's and are
pretty messy of different formats even
if they come from reputable digital
archives Smithsonian Rutgers and and
Michigan
Hamilton a number but but still no
transcript attract what we want to be
able to say is in this instance the
relationship Mary Lou Williams played
with is can be expressed by the
predicate collaborated with from the mo
music ontology so these are all the
possible some that many other
possibility but relationship that can be
recorded in tooling data so here is a
spectrum of a possibility of things that
can be said about the link between two
people knows of knows by reputation
knows in passing a smack nose
acquaintance of close friend of
influenced by collaborated with mentor
of obviously the nuances oh that
expressive thus Priscilla T of this
relationship is tied to the options we
have so what the vocab words yes and
that the namespace are the fourth
namespace for example this is a very
well it's one of the most adopted
established vocabulary or rel is a
relationship vocab amusing ontology is a
very established for couples and so
these are the vocab words that say
something about the relationship of
people there is a number of vocabularies
but these are the most established and
the more established your somatic is
it's more likely that you can support
and force enable interlinking yes yeah
that is true it this kind of information
is yes it is important is offered by
Skog raphy it's something that you can
certainly find out just by mapping data
sets we did it pre collaboration for
example we did it with with other data
set but you cannot understand or you
cannot get the social relationships well
you have yeah the collaborated is true
that can be can be fun but what we did
actually hear it doesn't show yet but
you can click on collaborating you have
different nuances of collaborations but
it's also true that collaborative with
this rental lay the low-hanging fruit is
not a great discovery too because it's
it's obvious from them from the
discography and it can be performed
automatically we use this because from
our from the feedback we receive from
jazz musician just modern jazz musician
just historians this is a critical
relationship for them and so they want
to see the nuances yeah but well this is
the final tool so when I said when
transcript needs to be organized
structured build up in a way that you
are these nipples of information of the
questions and answers in sequence and
all the people on your left they are
mentioned so this is not an obvious task
to accomplish and this is done through
another curatorial tool called
transcript analyzer
look i'm sure i'm giving a very sloppy
description of its quite complex
actually but it's for the user is easy
you upload your your your transcript and
you map your names with with the
directory on your left basically through
a natural language process technology
all the names are identified the blue
names are easy not problematic names but
when you have a Bock Bock Bock really
you you need some kind of curation and
what the tool allows you to do among
other things he is to reconcile the
partial names when there is a full name
in the neighbor or 12 a way to look up
through authorities or other sources and
it's able to go in this case this what
it did and then you you map against this
and it's this tool is able also to
identify other kind of entities besides
names and it's it has it has a high
performance value so it's named entity
recognition of some elk when you deal
with textual documents where you need to
identify cities places periods periods
of times or names
user interfaces when you get yes like
channel and she don't posle which are
commonly misunderstood but this is way
there were cousins but they not the same
people frequently the music of you know
is it tributed to channel but Jenna was
already dead well in this case you
disambiguate the names but you can do
some some search if you are really
desperate and confused you can look at
one of the you can look at the web and
and basically yeah map your names it's
pretty rare that we find names are not
anywhere even the most obscure musician
have been I've entered the Wikipedia but
at this point well what is left to say
is I have started to put together a
catalog of LOD open issues and ongoing
challenges and so we can just very
quickly I can just mention that there is
a need for more applications that
consume this data we saw that for now we
have prototypes and people have started
to work on that need for user-friendly
visual interfaces as entry points for
users obviously users cannot interface
for example the British Museum data
through a sparkle query window there is
a need for methoden services for
enforcing the data quality and is what a
lot of people are doing now to enforce
integrity accuracy trustworthiness for
example in our triples we add another
line to state the provenance of the
information we provide and so this is
because no we think that for archival
context is incredibly important to give
the source of your data
and also for the statements of that
express the relationship from people we
want to be able to say well this person
is a close friend of this other person
based on this source yes
the code is available in part is
available on our website and everything
we are developing is open access and
shared so in part is my yeah yeah some
the code that is not available yet is
because we are working on on the tools
and they are not they have not been
launched yeah like the crowdsourcing is
in the face of casting now so it's not I
mean I think we will launch it in the
summer at some point what is available
is that our vocabulary there is a file
at this point on the website with all
the names of the musicians we recorded
as triples and everything else would be
would be available well and just to
really enter the talk the reason well
this is one of the challenges I have
talked much about but there is a need
for query math of the scale across the
unbounded web so so far we have seen the
interlinking of well-established
datasets dbpedia Library of Congress
geonames these are very very very
reliable data set but the interlinking
in the open web this poses some issues
of scalability especially because the
sparkle query language is probably not
strong enough and this is a matter of
creating a layer of a stronger
functionality
so creating and finally has for the
opportunities I was and with what
someone at the Lord lamb sim Sam it's
two years ago said it was lot lamb is
this community of linked open data for
libraries and museums emerging community
self-organized what people know get
together every two years to discuss the
developmental linked open data and I
think the spirit of linked open data is
capturing saying the best thing to do to
your data will be thought of by someone
else so we put out data we build some
applications but is really is not a
prescriptive environment you don't
prescribe how this data will be used so
someone else might have much better
ideas on what they make how to make the
most of these semantics I think it's
pretty much what i wanted to share thank
you questions early with the
crowdsourcing tool but are you planning
to do any kind of evaluation on whether
you know manual or bags
of the other contributions you get back
in the south yes we are designing a
study to evaluate a contribution to
evaluate well to evaluate what it takes
to create an affecting crown sorting
tools or what are the motivations what
are the features that can engage users
what are the elements that important to
create this connection between a
community and and the project actually
we are we have a paper coming up at
digital humanities conference in July
about the design issues and features of
other crowdsourcing tool and yes it is
extremely interesting to see and and
from our point of view the harnessing of
the knowledge should be balanced by
offering the possibility to learn and so
that's why we are designing new features
in a way that the volunteers can also
gained a reward in learning something
new and also building community so there
will be there will be features spaces
for comments for providing their
knowledge but also to connect and it's a
very generous community and and the
initial feedback was very positive
people are expecting to work on this
tool and so yeah that's evaluation it's
part or isn't ongoing activity with with
these tools now we are testing the
interface just a usability of the
interface and then we will yes Alex what
is the other thing so far by garbagemen
sorry spectacle is a scooter because it
is very slow in my research reference
source
anitha Greta this little demon on
graduate students about through a star
by a favor and you want to start seeing
some these things right but then you
want to move up before they're gone be
required to move beyond those nasal
connections but you work with scholars
already who said i discovered this thing
that I mean our we expect that to happen
we are hoping that this happens but we
got good feedback from the people we've
been interested in actually surprisingly
probably because of the social media but
the judge community who York is looking
at this stuff and then there are number
of people working already on this crowd
sourcing to that is not it has not been
launched yet so what the when you see
the blue there was no that the blue
under some of the transcript because
people they started to work on on on
analyzing these relationships I don't
know what we are going to do with those
with this data but people are already
naturally engaged and I think also in
our group now I work with students our
student at Pratt they're fantastic
students we have jazz musician that
happens in New York and even some of
your students are musicians and so
they've have directed back from from
them already musicians sorry one is a
musician but one is a journalist is a
suggestion or analysis and so he asked
your attitude to the community and we
are expecting engagement we know we have
to also to work hard to to offer
features for engagement yeah and we
talked with with a number of researchers
and Columbia Rutgers and they showed
interest for it a tools that have to
analyze date in a new way and you have
to think that now we are doing the hard
stuff of analyzing their relationships
but hopefully we will be able to
aggregate
many other pieces of information even
songs and and and and dates and advance
together this we think it's not the hard
part it would be the fun part but the
hard part now is to find out what is the
nature of the personal relationship with
in between people yes when the group of
the sea librarian stabilo seems even
hello and I was thinking it I mean we
only dated projects be an alternative to
what we think of as a library catalog
where it's just you know aggregated
space and mcallister different folders
what the library community is
positioning towards working with linked
data with the new bed frame and so it
could be certainly an extension like
linked data in relations to the web to
the traditional web is not a replacement
it's just a new layer of semantics is an
extension of the existing website
nothing is going to change if you don't
want it to change which of these new
opportunities so I think for the library
catalog would be would be the same
especially with the new standard RDA
with all the work that has been done in
converting legacy data legacy metadata
in so I think it will be an environment
what we will see more and more of linked
data the librarians have invested
enormous expectations and energy in this
and that's why I think that compared to
the Semantic Web that never happened
linked data and has involved so many
parties heavily and so it's a matter I
think of emergence at some point it will
emerge and I think we are very close to
well Aussie Aussie is well they find in
my project at the beginning they are
they're very interested doing themselves
a lot of a work for example with VR and
a number of initiatives on names so they
are working on on linked data will be
probably linked data not linked open
data but I don't know really haven't
explored the openness of but I know
there is a lot of research going on yeah
basically so whatever relationship
display metadata and mixed data and it
is how it is rubble to could decide to
convert metadata is selectively another
corner of mods or adds to water standard
in liquidator all this mall on North
Dublin core they if they are converted
into link data format they become linked
data I don't know if there is a need to
really make a distinction between data
and metadata at this point when
everything is translated in a common
language and so the dublin core can
offers you the predicates create or all
subject of whatever element dublin core
has to offer to say Thelonious Monk has
subject and then you are the subject
heading from lab of Congress in your
your I format so it's it's a way of
interlinking all this information
according to your needs
so I metadata and data becomes
interlinear ball and it's usable but you
don't use XML data XML is just a
serialization serialization format and
so let's MLA can be there it's a syntax
of RDF so it's it's the way you express
an idea if it can be through XML it
could be through other other formats one
is tor tor what it JS I mean there are
different ways you so certain Jason it
is a form of expressing is a syntax for
for rdf xml swords you can express it
not not an extra novelty if you can
explore everything else you can express
also in something else that all yes it's
an easy conversion from an RV f / xml
into another format but it's it's it's
all cold and all these triples will work
together pretty well so what I'm saying
is the boundaries of the institutions
are becoming more blurry and this is one
of I didn't want to bring up the silos
buzzword but it's really what link data
allows us to do to break down the
institutional barriers between maim or
institution if we think about cultural
heritage so who cares if the description
of a museum object is sitting in a
digital library database or everything
can be mashed up the idea is matching up
but not the way we do mashups now where
we have closed systems they don't talk
to each other
since they don't have a common naming
method you cannot leave different mashup
systems with linked data you can perform
truly mashup between museum libraries
archives and the external world yes it's
an every problem other fatigues of India
is a little sore from the you are so
when I say for example what is a pig a
pig Atari game ET right this is that
this is a problem caused by by
Australian folks who sit in theaters
well it's it's a cartridge no it's
actually it's just a series of codes no
it's an interactive experience that we
have when we play no it's actually just
brand name in proliferate still is in a
coordination way it's actually for
Gaston problem with with categories the
doc why is it all you know is if we
build a man in a world in which it would
take a second hundred years for us to
map out every often and still we would
have been permissible well you mean is
the problem of identity of objects and
well you give context to your statements
you make claims with our DF they are
situated in your language so if I see
something using a dbpedia
identifier it's situated in that context
and the trust that you provide is it
straight to the level of traffic that
data set but then you create and I don't
know if I Alex I find answering your
question actually well you know there is
something to be said with linked data
link data words with the level of
tolerance that was not possible with
semantic web where these hard problems
of identity well we're dealt with with
very complex logical languages we got
rid of these languages because it can
work her logical formalization can work
in very constraints constrain domain but
in our context we as who has been
adopted a more flexible approach of
would say good enough you make assertion
of similar you say something is the same
as something else with a close match
without too much formalization because
it works well enough so the problem of
modeling know all models are wrong some
are useful how rigorous you want to be
as much as you're told works this
approach of linked data this kind of a
relief that people work with Lynn data
feel I don't know I mean it is a new way
of working with masi data link data is
full of messiness semantic noise we just
try to deal with this building tools to
map up things and to tolerate
more nastiness then a control
environment is a trade-off between a
controlled environment and it an open
database has the web and it's one of the
challenges actually but no thank you
thank you